featuring these two gentlemen we're
going to compare their numbers this
season Victor wanyama and Chad holgren
you can see they're very impressive the
rookies are showing up and showing out I
mean even on on both sides of the ball
you can see points at the top but then
look at the blocks and the rebounds
those numbers are also very good as we
welcome you back inside our studio let's
hear from our resident experts these two
rookies those are the two that everyone
is saying one of them will be rookie of
the year so now we get to see them for
the first time go head-to-head play
against each other Isaiah what is it
about these two young men that makes
them so special I Greg pointed this out
earlier they they're in the right
situations right
coaches right programs that allow them
to play they're not no one is saying to
these two Thin SF Footers that they got
to put on 40 lbs they have to play a
different way that they're adjusting
their gains to their skills and this is
what papovich is doing with wimy I mean
wimy the thing to me that's most
impressive about wimy is that Greg
Stephanie he he has no idea where he's
even traveling to right because he he's
from France So when you say we're going
to Milwaukee he's never been to
Milwaukee so geographically like he's
all messed up but give him another 30
days when he gets another 30 40 days
under his belt and he knows where the
water cooler is at he knows where the
bathroom is at and he can get
comfortable in a hotel room macaroon oh
man he he's going to be killing it yeah
he he's they're both incredible the the
thing about Chad Chad is like a plug-in
play type of player right cuz he's a guy
in a lot of ways he played This Way Gaga
right he can space the floor he can make
a a three he's a solid passer he's going
to compete defensively in terms of the
shot blocking and rebounding he can
guard all five positions out on the
floor but he does the little things that
allow you to win you know he'll do those
things that don't often times show up in
the stat sheet and I think that's why
he's been such a a great fit for OKC
whereas with with Victor he's going to
be I think more of a primary focal point
for your offense I think he's a guy that
is going to be a 30 point a game score
uh it's going to be a terrific
facilitator and he also can get after
defensively at 74 he's a he's a skill
player on the perimeter although
defensively he can still be very
impactful and you you know what's
interesting like we're talking about
these two guys as rookie of the year now
four years from now or three years from
now across the league you're going to
need a guy like this right to compete
and win because if you don't have one of
these type of players two three years
from now you're out yeah daunting that's
very daunting if you're a general
manager in this league
yeah